baghdad is on high alert for the first
ever visit to iraq by the leader of the
roman catholic church
iraq still faces security threats and
attacks from isil and militia groups
which means the iraqi security forces
have their work cut out for them
as pope francis will be in six cities in
three days
all requirements have been secured
through a plan drawn up by the joint
operations command to secure logistical
and security matters
for all the places that the pope will
visit whether they are in baghdad najaf
nineveh edible all places pope francis
has frequently traveled to muslim
majority countries
and in iraq he will meet one of the
world's most influential shia clerics
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani the
pope's visit is meant to expand
on his message of interfaith dialogue
and bring hope to iraq's christian
community
but it also comes during a pandemic to a
country
which has not started vaccinating its
people and is imposing partial lockdowns
to try and stop the spread of covet 19.
the vatican's ambassador to iraq who
would have escorted the pope to all his
appointments
has already tested positive pope francis
and his entourage have been vaccinated
and organizers say they will strictly
enforce crowd limits at public events
but with the sharp rise in iraq's covert
19 cases and a weak healthcare system
critics have questioned the
effectiveness of social distancing
as it's expected crowds will gather to
see the pope
actor some people close to the pope
believe that the visit should be
postponed due to the pandemic and
security situation
but the pope insisted on his visit iraq
needs his visit and he feels the pain of
the people who are suffering
iraqi authorities say all necessary
steps to ensure the safety and security
of all involved are being taken
the civil defense plan has two
components first part is protection
firefighters and rescuers will be in all
places to be visited by his holiness
and the second part is sterilization of
all places without exception
it will be in coordination with those in
charge of churches and holy sites
that will be included in the visit of
his holiness iraqi christians can trace
their lineage to the earliest days of
the religion
they are a diverse group with syriac
azirian chaldean
armenian and malkite communities since
the 2003 u.s invasion and later the
persecution suffered under isil
the visit is a rare opportunity to lift
broken spirits among a dwindling
christian population
but iraqis of all faiths are excited
about welcoming pope francis
baba as he is affectionately known in
arabic although
like that